you were in can yeah and you were
performing at a big event in can and who
was it for
the Oh was the event was it was devoted
you were yeah you were honoring John
Travolta votive it was like a the gaudy
premiere like they had it out there
yeah and they had called me because uh
pit bull like I got sick like he was
that guy you know face time like this
yeah yeah that's funny when pit bull
gets sick I don't get called yeah no one
wants me as the replacement for pit ball
that's great though so you you think pit
bull couldn't do it yeah it was really
last-minute say called UN and Europe on
stage and you're wrapping right and
killing it and Travolta I was told jumps
up on stage just came he's just like
really I didn't see him at first it was
like I was performing so room was a real
you like what's going and I'm a big fan
John's was like what's he doing that I
mean was he doing he wasn't doing it
wasn't doing that it was doing some news
I don't even know like I'm trying to
check out what he's doing to say the
words at the same time it was like look
they had like a hundred and twenty
million views yeah well you two yeah we
actually I want to show it to people
because we we got it obviously so many
people saw it this is you rapping and
then of course as you would expect when
you see fitty cent performing John
Travolta comes out dancing
[Applause]
[Music]
still got moves yeah for a second it
looked to me like a waiter had just come
out
kick back to your table I can't man
you